-It's good?
[ Laughter ]
Labradoodle.
-The llama shoe.
-Labradoodle.
-Llama shoe.
-Labbadah -- Sorry. Okay.
-Labradoodle.
-It looks like llama shoe.
I know you're not saying that.
-Not llama shoe.
This is "llama shoe." Not that.
-Slap shoe.
-No, no.
Ready? No, that wasn't real.
[ Laughter ]
[Southern accent]
Labradoodle.
[ Laughter ]
-One more. One more.
-[Deep voice] Labradoodle.
-Llama --
It looks like llama shoe. I...
[ Laughter ]
-It's not llama shoe!
Labradoodle.
-Labba shoe. Lappa...
[ Panting ]
A Shih Tzu.
[ Laughter ]
-No. Labradoodle.
Doodle. Doodle.
-Llama shoe.
[ Laughter ]
It looks like llama shoe
every time.
[ Laughter ]
I know you're not saying that.
-Labradoodle.
-Lava shoe.
-Doo.
-Shoe.
-Doo. Doo.
[ Funky music plays ]
No. No, no.
Labradoo--
-Lapping.
Labradoodle.
-Lapping dog.
-Labradoodle. Yeah. Dog.
-Poodle.
-Yeah! Ah!
-La-- Sounds like a poodle.
A Labradoodle!
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
♪♪
[ Voices whispering ]
-Whisper Challenge...
-Reese Witherspoon.
-Reese Witherspoon?
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You did this!
-I didn't look at it!
I love Reese Witherspoon.
That's fantastic!
-Next time I'm gonna go...
-[ Laughs ] Don't do that. I
didn't know what you were doing.
Alright. Ready? Here we go.
[ Music playing on headphones ]
-Oh.
-Yeah. That's good.
Huh?
[ Laughter ]
-Bondi Beach.
[bondy]
-Um. One more.
-Bondi Beach.
-A buzzing beach. A bud beach.
-Banana Beach!
-Bondi Beach.
-Bada beach.
-Badaba.
-Bondi Beach.
-I'm getting worse.
-You're speaking Italian now.
Sorry. Sorry. Here we go.
Bondi Beach.
-Bella -- B-- [ Laughs ]
This is so hard!
-[British accent]
Bondi.
-Bone she. Boshe--
[ Laughter ]
I know I'm not saying
anything English.
-[Normal voice]
Bondi Beach.
-Push in a beach.
-[ Laughter ]
-Push in a beach. No.
-Bondi Beach.
-Oh, bond-eye. Sorry. Bond-eye.
Of course.
I was saying it wrong.
-Was I yelling?
-Bondi -- No, not at all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't tell her.
-It's so hard.
-No, you were not yelling. No.
Alright. Come on.
We can do it. Here we go.
-I don't even know what I said.
I think I spoke gibberish.
This is so much harder
than I thought.
Okay.
Fuggedaboutit.
-Think about it.
-Fuggedaboutit.
Fuggedaboutit!
-Fuggedaboutit!
-Think about it!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Alright. Here's the --
Here's the first one. Ready?
[ Chuckles ]
Did you do it?!
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-Pumpkin spice latte.
-Say it one more time.
[ Laughter ]
-Pumpkin spice latte.
-My peepee's stretched out?
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, man! That's not
even close to the word!
Ready?
[ Sad tuba plays ]
Pumpkin...spice...latte.
-My pee pee...
I know it's "my pee pee."
[ Laughter ]
I swear to God, this is --
What is this?
-Stop yelling at me!
Let's try it one more time.
-One more time.
-Alright. I'll take that
as a win. That counts.
-[ Bell dinging ]
-Did I get it?
Pumpkin spice latte.
-Here we go. I'm gonna
try it now. Here we go.
-This is the stupidest thing,
literally,
I have ever been a part of
in my entire career.
-Alright. Go. Go. I can't hear.
You can't hear? It is so loud.
[ Music playing on headphones ]
-I don't -- I don't even know
how to say this. Okay.
Benedict Cumberbatch.
-Billy Eisner compromises.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
Benedict.
Cumberbatch.
Benedict Cumberbatch.
-Benedict Cumberbatch!
[ Bell dinging ]
I knew that was it!
That was it? That was it!
No, we're playing together.
We're playing --
-There is no way.
-Yeah, I swear. That was great.
-That doesn't
even mean anything.
-He's nominated for an Oscar!
-Who?!
-Yes. Put your headphones on.
-That's a person?
-You got to
get out of the house, man.
-I've never even heard of that.
-There you go.
A very famous actor.
Very famous actor.
-This is bullcrap.
-Alright. Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, boy. Uh, okay.
Cobra Kai.
-Show me the knockies.
[ Laughter ]
Cobra Kai.
-One more time.
-Cobra Kai.
[ Laughter ]
-Sh-- Show me...
-Don't say tanakis again, man.
Co-bra.
Cobra.
-Cobra!
-Kai.
-Karate! Cobra karate.
-Close enough. Close enough.
-Did I get it? Did I get it?
-Cobra Kai.
You ever seen "Karate Kid"?
Ah, forget it. Uh...
Stars Benedict Cumberbatch
and Ralph Macchio.
Alright. Here we go.
Last one. Here we go.
-What --
These are the dumbest phrases.
[ Laughter ]
I know this one.
50 Shades of Grey.
-50 Shades of Grey!
[ Bell dinging ]
You're good.
-Very good. Here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
Oh, my goodness.
-It's gonna be really tough
for me to guess!
-Alright. Wait. Hold on.
-Am I talking loud?!
-Yes! Yes!
-I a-- Okay.
-Alright. Ready?
-So I need to whisper
a little bit.
Do I whisper or do you whisper?
-No.
-Okay.
-You're fine!
-Jimmy, I can't hear you.
-Alright.
-Okay. [ Clears throat ]
I got this.
Appletini.
-What?!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ohh!
-How'd you get that?
-He was right.
We're all winners.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude, no one's ever got it
on the first one.
How did you get appletini?
-Listen to the music
you gave me, man.
It's just a loop that says
"appletini, appletini."
I'm kidding. It's not.
It is, though. It's not.
-Gosh. That was fant--
That was the best one ever.
I can't believe
you just did that.
Alright.
Whoa. Whoa. Whoa.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Welcome to my world.
Alright. Hey. Okay.
[ Clears throat ]
Shama Lama Ding Dong.
-Slap m-- Slap my lap.
-No! No.
Shama Lama Ding Dong.
-Slappa lappa ding dong.
-Al--
-Shama Lama Ding Dong?
-Yeah!
[ Bell dinging ]
Yeah.
-This is unbelievable.
We got it, man. We got this.
See? This is good.
We both win,
and it makes everyone feel good.
[ Laughs ] Gosh.
Alright. Ready for this one?
-Alright.
-Okay.
-This is gonna be easy.
That's not fair.
You didn't say anything.
He -- [ Mumbles ]
-WrestleMania 33.
-WrestleMania 33!
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Got two.
-Easiest one we've ever played.
Alright.
I'm ready for this, man.
Let's go.
I'm --I'm excited. Appletini.
Got real heavy.
-This one is not easy.
-Okay, okay, okay.
But I think we're good.
We have good chemistry.
-Yeah. No. Wait. Wait. Okay.
Start. [ Clears throat ]
Didgeridoo.
[ Laughter ]
-Do it again. Slower.
-Did...ger...
-Dick your...
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Ditch!
-Didgeri...doo.
-Did you...
Did...
-Dick.
-...ger...
-Nose.
-No dick.
-No. Okay. No? Okay.
Didger...
-Did...
-Dree-dree?
Doo.
Did--
-Didgeridoo?
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're all winners.
-Didgeridoo.
That's what I'm talking about.
John Cena, everybody!
Oh, my gosh. Alright. Ready?
Alright. Ready? Ready?
Here we go.
[ Music playing on headphones ]
[ Laughter ]
Salted peanuts.
-Do -- Now I say it?
-Yes.
-Do I take this off?
-No.
-Sausage penis?
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
I really thought that.
Try it again.
-Salted peanuts.
-Oh! Sausage pizza?
No? Do I take it off?
-Yeah, that's it, right? Yeah.
So you take it off now.
You take it off. Yeah. Alright.
-What happened?
-Salted peanuts.
-Oh! Hey, I was close!
-That was good. Yeah.
Now I'm gonna try.
-Alright. This is hilarious.
-Alright. Thank you.
-Oh. Okay.
Ready? Okay.
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
[ Clears throat ]
Uptown Funk You Up.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Uptown Funk You Up.
-You can't say that.
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna...
Ohh! Oh!
Uptown Funk You Up.
-Ohh!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Yes! Oh!
I put two and two together.
I knew you couldn't say that.
Of course!
"Don't believe me. Just watch."
Yeah, of course. That was great!
-That was great!
You're good at this.
-Thank you.
Yeah, you're good, too.
We're a good team.
-Okay. You ready?
-Yeah, I guess so.
-This is so much fun.
I could do this for hours.
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm.
Hoda Kotb.
-Origami.
No?
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Hoda Kotb.
-Huh?
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on.
-Hoda Kotb.
-One more time.
-Oh, God, help me.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ Laughter ]
I'm doing the best I can.
Do I take these off?
-Yeah. Sorry. Hoda Kotb.
-Oh, for [bleep] -- Oh!
-Hoda Kotb.
Sorry. Hoda Kotb.
I was trying to say it.
Alright. Last one.
We'll do the last one here.
-Yeah.
-Here we go. Ready?
You're awesome. That was close.
-This is a gas.
Okay. You ready?
Wipe that smile off your face.
-Wimpin' smithers words.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-No.
Wipe that smile off your face.
-Women's smelly overalls.
-One more time.
Alright. We got it.
-Was I talking that loud?
Okay. [ Clears throat ]
Wipe that smile off your face.
-Go -- Go slow!
Can you do it again slower?
-Yeah, I can!
-Wait, wait. Sorry. Silence.
It's silence in the song.
-Wait. Don't say anything.
Uh-oh.
The system's breaking down.
-I'm back. I'm back.
-Alright. Ready? Okay.
Wipe that smile off your face.
-My left wrist, my right wrist.
No. What was it?
-Wipe that smile off your face.
-[ Laughs ]
I can't ever do that.
Julia Louis-Dreyfus, my pal!
A beautiful day
in the neighborhood.
-A boot full of...
-A beautiful day --
a beautiful day --
-A boat full --
What?
-A beautiful day
in the neighborhood.
-A beautiful day in the
neighborhood.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What?!
How did you know that?
Did you peek at my card?
-No, you have
very readable lips.
-It is, uh --
It is my turn here.
Let's see how I do.
-You do it now?
-Yeah.
-Oh, okay.
-Sorry.
Oh, yeah.
I like this.
I want to download this.
-You should.
-Okay.
-Yeah? Yep, yep, yep, yep.
I have a shoplifting problem.
-I have --
-I have a serious
shoplifting problem.
Stealing makes me feel big.
-Cheddar cheese?
-I steal everything.
Groceries, books, cold medicine.
I know I'm sick,
but I can't help myself.
-Help?
-It's like a high to me.
I love the danger of
almost getting caught.
-Slow down. Slow down.
Slow down.
-Can you imagine the headlines?
"Will Ferrell arrested for
shoplifting at Kohl's."
God, that'd be so humiliating.
-Beer koozie.
-But what can I say?
It turns me on.
-Attorney at law?
I have no clue. I'm sorry.
-No, it was Baby Yoda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I should have gotten Baby Yoda.
That's pretty famous.
You were just saying Baby Yoda
over and over?
-Do I go?
-Yeah, you go.
-Okay. You put on
the headphones.
Imposs--
-Impossible Whopper.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-How?
-It's a gift. It's a gift.
Your turn.
-Okay. Alright.
We'll do one more round.
-One more round? Okay.
-I'm feeling good about this.
Okay, let's do it. Come on.
I can do it. I can do it.
-Do you like cults?
I'm starting one,
and guess what --
you're my first member.
I've already seized
your bank accounts
and stolen your identity.
You shouldn't
leave your e-mail open.
Do you know how easy
it is to find
a Social Security number?
I'm going to erase you.
-Shush? California raisins?
-We'll worship
Jonathan Lipnicki as a god.
We're going to use your money
to build a temple
dedicated to the
Jonathan Lipnicki movie
"The Little Vampire."
And your new legal name
will be Jonathan Lopnocki,
because it's as close as we can
get to naming you
after our new god
without angering him.
-Anger management?
-I'm gonna dye your hair blond
and make you wear
little, round glasses.
And instead of "hello,"
you'll greet me by saying,
"Did you know that the human
head weighs 8 pounds?"
And then, I'll say, "Really?
Let's find out for ourselves."
And that's when I'm gonna pop
your pretty little head off
like a [bleep] dandelion.
All it takes is a dull knife
and 10 minutes.
And that's when
I take your glasses
and I put them on my own face
and then I see what God sees.
Then I see what our god,
Jonathan Lipnicki, sees.
-"Then I see what our god,
Jonathan Lipnicki, sees."
Nailed it.
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
You got it.
-Great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're good --
-Yeah.
-We're good at this.
Will Ferrell, everybody!